vamos a ver los tipos principales de
estudios estadísticos podemos tener un
estudio de muestreo del cual ya hemos
hablado en otros vídeos y que veremos
nuevamente en este vídeo podemos tener
un estudio observacional
o podemos tener un experimento
vamos a ver cada uno de estos y como
siempre los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de imaginar qué
significan cada uno de estos términos o
quizás ya saben que se refiere ya hemos
visto el estudio de muestreo y esto se
refiere esto trata de cuando queremos
conocer el valor del parámetro de una
población veamos un ejemplo digamos que
tomamos la población de una ciudad que
puede ser de cientos de miles de
personas y el parámetro que nos interesa
es el tiempo promedio que las personas
pasan en una computadora así que el
parámetro será para toda la población si
pudiéramos hablar con cada una de las
personas de esta población
imaginando no sé que sean un millón de
personas y pudiéramos hablar con este
millón de personas y preguntarles del
tiempo que pasan diariamente usando una
computadora pues nosotros calculamos el
promedio de todo esto y ya tendríamos el
valor de nuestro parámetro así que esta
es mi población
y el parámetro que me interesa de esta
población es el promedio diario del
tiempo que pasan en la computadora
y en la realidad es poco práctico ir a
hablar con cada una de estas personas
que forman esta población de 1 millón de
personas para hacerles esta pregunta así
que no podremos calcular exactamente el
parámetro que nos interesa de esta
población por lo que en su lugar vamos a
hacer un estudio de muestreo vamos a
muestrear aleatoriamente aunque hay
muchas consideraciones para hacer que
nuestro muestreo sea realmente aleatorio
de igual manera tenemos diferentes
técnicas para este muestreo aleatorio
pero digamos que nosotros realizamos
este muestreo así que muestre amos
aleatoriamente de esta población y
después calculamos el promedio del
tiempo que pasa en cada día en una
computadora y este será un valor
estimado del parámetro que me interesa
este es un ejemplo clásico de estudio de
muestreo ahora en un estudio
observacional no vamos a tratar de
estimar un parámetro vamos a tratar de
comprender como dos parámetros en una
población podrían estar relacionados
ahora digamos que tenemos una población
de 1.000 personas y queremos saber si el
tiempo diario que pasa en frente a una
computadora tiene o no alguna relación
con la presión arterial de estas
personas así que tenemos el tiempo en la
computadora
contra la presión arterial y lo que
hacemos es aplicar una encuesta a toda
la población de 1000 personas y se les
pregunta el tiempo diario usando una
computadora y cuál es su presión
arterial o quizá la medimos de cierta
manera gráfica moss la información la
analizamos y vemos si estas dos
variables tienen alguna relación qué
significa esto pues vamos a dibujar unos
ejes coordinados digamos que este eje es
el tiempo en la computadora y este otro
eje es el de la presión arterial digamos
que tenemos una persona que pasa
relativamente poco tiempo en la
computadora y tiene baja presión
arterial tenemos a otra persona que pasa
mucho tiempo en la computadora y tiene
la presión arterial alta y tenemos a
alguien que quizás no pasa demasiado
tiempo en la computadora pero tiene una
presión arterial relativamente alta
seguimos graficando la información y
obtenemos estos puntos de esas mil
personas aquí no vamos a dibujar los mil
puntitos
pero digamos que ven algo así y vemos
que aunque tenemos algunos valores
atípicos pareciera que estas dos
variables están relacionadas pareciera
que en general mientras más tiempo se
pasa en la computadora más alta será la
presión arterial o mientras veamos una
presión arterial más alta veremos un
mayor tiempo en la computadora así que
podríamos tomar una conclusión aquí de
que estas dos variables están
correlacionadas hay una correlación
positiva si es que hicimos
apropiadamente el estudio podríamos
decir que mientras más tiempo se pasa en
la computadora esto se va a
correlacionar con la presión arterial
alta o que la presión arterial alta se
relaciona con un mayor tiempo en la
computadora cuando hacemos o
interpretamos estos estudios
observacionales o cuando leemos el
estudio de alguien más es muy importante
no llegar a la conclusión de que es que
es el tiempo de computadora lo que causa
que me aumente la presión arterial ya
que esto no está mostrando causalidad
también se podría decir que la presión
arterial
alta hace que las personas pasen más
tiempo en la computadora lo que suena un
poco tonto pero es lo mismo aquí lo que
estamos diciendo es que hay una
correlación entre estas dos variables se
mueven juntas pero no podemos hacer una
conclusión sobre lo que causa esto que
el tiempo en computadora causa la
presión arterial o que la presión
arterial ocasiona un mayor tiempo en la
computadora porque no podemos decir esto
porque podríamos tener una variable que
nos confunda no sé digamos que ese es el
tiempo de computadora
y esta es la presión arterial y
pareciera que estas dos cosas están
relacionadas ya que se mueven juntas eso
lo vimos aquí en nuestros datos pero
podríamos tener una variable raíz que
está guiando a estas dos variables que
quizá podría ser la falta de actividad
física podría ser la falta de actividad
lo que esté ocasionando ambas variables
las personas que son menos activas
quizás pasan más tiempo en la
computadora y las personas que son menos
activas quizás tienen mayor presión
arterial y si tenemos un control para
esto un grupo de personas que tuvieran
una falta de actividad es similar o un
nivel similar de actividad quizá
podríamos ver que el tiempo en la
computadora no está correlacionado con
la presión arterial que ambas están
ocasionadas por la misma variable de la
falta de actividad y quizá lo que vemos
aquí es que la actividad de la persona
es lo que está provocando el
comportamiento de estas dos variables si
ustedes hacen bien este tipo de estudios
observacionales
encontrar correlaciones que podrían
darles hipótesis decentes sobre
causalidad pero no es que esto muestre
una causalidad porque podríamos tener
estas variables que nos causan confusión
por otra parte tenemos los experimentos
y los experimentos son la base del
método científico
los experimentos tratan de establecer
causalidad lo que hacemos si queremos
hacer un experimento es y quizá no
podamos tomar a mil personas ya que los
experimentos son bastante difíciles de
realizar son los más difíciles de estos
tres tipos así que quizá tomamos a 100
personas y para evitar tener esta
variable que pueda provocar errores en
nuestro experimento vamos a asignar
aleatoriamente estas 100 personas a dos
grupos
esta es una asignación aleatoria y es
muy importante que sea de verdad
aleatorio y quizás no conozcamos todas
las variables al acecho aquí pero es
probable que cada grupo tenga asignado
una misma cantidad de personas que
tengan niveles de actividad similares
es más probable que el nivel de
actividad promedio en ambos grupos sea
el mismo si tenemos una asignación
aleatoria así que lo que hacemos es
tener un grupo de control y un grupo de
tratamiento y lo que podrían hacer es
decir bueno durante cierto tiempo estas
personas en el grupo de control podrán
pasar un máximo de 30 minutos en la
computadora o si queremos ser más
precisos vamos a decir que van a pasar
exactamente y solamente 30 minutos en la
computadora y en el grupo de tratamiento
vamos a decirles que van a pasar
exactamente 2 horas usando la
computadora y aquí yo estoy inventando
estos números y sería bueno conocer cuál
es la presión arterial de estas personas
antes de comenzar el experimento y ver
que sus promedios sean similares después
realizar el experimento durante cierto
tiempo y al final medir nuevamente la
presión arterial en los integrantes de
ambos grupos y si viéramos que este
grupo definitivamente tiene una presión
arterial más alta
y nuevamente algo de esto podría haber
ocurrido aleatoriamente pero depende si
este fue un experimento lo
suficientemente grande y se realizó de
manera correcta podríamos decir que
quizá haya una causalidad aquí ya que al
hacer que estas personas pasaran más
tiempo en la computadora esto hiciera
que aumentara su presión arterial así
que nuevamente el estudio de muestreo
trata de estimar el valor de un
parámetro de la población
el estudio observacional trata de ver si
hay correlación entre dos cosas y hay
que tener cuidado de no decir que una
cosa está causando la otra ya que
podemos tener variables que nos
confundan en un experimento tratamos de
establecer o mostrar causalidad y lo
hacemos tomando nuestro grupo asignar a
las personas aleatoriamente a un grupo
de control y a un grupo de tratamiento
lo que esperamos haga una distribución
equilibrada aunque no siempre es así
pero esperaríamos que se distribuyeran
equitativamente las
y en cada grupo controlamos la cantidad
de una de las variables para ver si ésta
está ocasionando a la otra variable en
los próximos vídeos veremos algunos
ejemplos de estos tipos de estudios
estadísticos y veremos que podemos
concluir de ello